on this episode of Imagine a world at
the end of this story everyone has an AI
advisor and has been interacting with
them for many years and has seen their
lives improve with the help of AI in so
many ways that they can no longer view
AI as mere tools because AI has been
acting like a person and helping them
for long enough that they've come to see
the AI as a friend or at least an
advisor
[Music]
welcome to imagine a world a mini series
from the future of Life Institute this
podcast is based on a contest we ran to
gather ideas from around the world about
what a more positive future might look
like in 2045
we hope the diverse ideas you're about
to hear will spark discussions and maybe
even collaborations but you should know
that the ideas in this podcast are not
to be taken as fli endorsed positions
and now over to our host Guillaume
reason
[Music]
welcome to the imagine a world podcast
by the future of Life Institute I'm your
host Guillaume reason in this episode
we'll be exploring a world called
Computing Council which was one of the
third place winners of fli's World
building contest
this world paints a vivid nuanced
picture of how emerging Technologies
shape Society
we have advertisers competing with ad
filtering Technologies in an escalating
arms race that eventually puts an end to
the internet as we know it there is AI
generated art so personalized that it
becomes addictive to some consumers
While others boycott media Technologies
altogether
and corporations begin to throw each
other under the bus in an effort to
redistribute the wealth of their
competitors to their own customers
while these conflicts are messy they
generally end up empowering and
enriching the lives of the people in
this world new kinds of AI systems give
them better data better advice and
eventually the opportunity for genuine
relationships with the beings these
tools have become
Our Guest today is Mark L one member of
the three-person team who created this
world
Mark is a machine learning expert with a
chemical engineering degree who also
likes to write short stories
one of his teammates Patrick is a
mechanical engineer and graphic designer
the other Natalia is a biological
anthropologist
all three share a love of creating art
both physical and digital
oh hey Mark it's great to have you with
us thanks gilm I'm glad to be here so
your team had three people on it there's
you there's Natalia and there's Patrick
I was just curious if you could say a
little bit about how you guys ended up
working on this together what motivated
you to enter and where your skill sets
came into play sure uh well I saw the
listing I think on an alignment forum
for this contest and uh it sounded
really compelling to write about the
future of AI it's something I'm
particularly interested in so I came to
the other two to Natalia and Patrick and
suggested to them that we enter this
contest not not because we thought we
were going to win actually but just as a
method of practice for our various art
forms so Patrick's much more into
digital art than writing but Natalia and
I are into writing so we we figured we'd
divide the work that way and get some
get some practice in and maybe we would
do fairly well in the competition or
maybe we wouldn't but the experience
would be worth it either way that's so
cool that the the practice itself was
alluring enough to draw you in even
without the promise of trying to
actually win the thing also
congratulations on actually winning the
thing
well we tried like we were going to win
and we set our expectations like yeah
yeah so uh that's the that's the best
way to do it actually entering
competitions is advice I would give to
any Creator uh even even competitions
without prizes or ones that you think
you have no chance from I kept entering
for example or irrational Reddit to
writing and competitions for a couple of
years and it gave me a lot of writing
practice that I wouldn't have had
otherwise yeah that makes sense
I'm also curious how your personal
perspective like where you live or your
professional background has influenced
how you were thinking about this future
and maybe you can speak to that for
Natalia and Patrick a little bit too
well personally
the chemical engineering background is
probably influencing the work quite a
lot you can see many references to
chemistry and physics it's hard not to
include those things as explanations
when you're trained on something over
several years it sort of becomes
fundamental to your to your world view
by the same token Patrick's training's
in mechanical engineering so there are
features of the world that have a
mechanical engineering bent like the use
of space tethers to lift spaceships
right Natalia and Patrick and I are all
in an art club together and that
probably influenced the work
significantly as well we have this
weekly tradition of collaborating on Art
so the idea that humans in the future
will collaborate in small groups with AI
was a natural thing to form well we
worked on this that's awesome how big is
your art Club how many people are in it
it changes from week to week uh usually
there's at least four or five people
there seldom more than six though yeah
that sounds like a really cool community
of practice it's cool that you all have
this mixture of kind of like sciency and
creative backgrounds what is Natalia's
scholarly background or education
biological anthropology gotcha very cool
yeah it's good she makes sure that it's
not only Tech in our worlds but also
reasonable humans yeah so what was your
workflow like when you were working on
this with Natalia and Patrick the first
thing I did was I wrote the two short
stories and then natai and I spent time
brainstorming events that could go in
the timeline that led to that I had a
very amorphous idea of the timeline but
filling out the details uh really
allowed it to come together then I went
to Art Club and presented this to
Patrick and the other members of Art
Club to get their feedback on it and
Patrick volunteered to make some art for
it when I explained the contest I see so
the art club and particularly Alex and
ryu's contributions in terms of feedback
really made a big difference to the
quality of the story yeah shout out to
Art Club everyone in there including
Alex and Ryu yep so after I had their
feedback I changed the stories and the
timeline a little bit and
removed the parts that were particularly
implausible and fix the parts that were
particularly unclear then Natalia and
Patrick read it one more time and we
sent it on
[Music]
the impact of any technology on society
is complex and multifaceted this world
does a great job of capturing that
while social networking Technologies
become ever more powerful the networks
of people they connect don't necessarily
just get wider and shallower
instead they tend to be smaller and more
intimately interconnected
the world's inhabitants also have
nuanced attitudes towards AI tools
embracing or avoiding their applications
based on their religious or
philosophical beliefs
change over time with public sentiment
shifting from an initial dismissal of
agis as persons towards something more
inclusive and respectful
While most of the world's inhabitants
would probably consider things to be
improved in 2045. there's still a clear
sense of ongoing change growth and moral
Reckoning this isn't the end of our
story
what's it like to be in your world in
2045 how do people find fulfillment or
what does a good life look like one of
the major changes that I think I didn't
perhaps communicate well enough when
writing my world is that social groups
have shrank from their massive excess in
our modern times you don't hop on
Twitter and instantly reach 10 000
people instead you send messages to a
small group of friends perhaps 20 to 100
which I think evolutionarily is the is
the size of the optimal human group but
that's a digression the point is is
people find fulfillment In This World by
interacting with their friends their
limited pool of friends 20 to 100 and
not all people but many people find
fulfillment in impressing that small
group of people with their own Creations
or their own ideas or their own
Communications
it's a a world where you know that you
can't compete on the world stage but the
hundred people you care about you can
impress them at least yeah I like that
it's more kind of intimate socializing
you do also mention people doing things
like participating in clinical trials
and doing science competitions I imagine
clinical trials might be like something
that we need humans for for complicated
biological reasons but with some of
these other things is there really a
need for humans to be engaging in these
roles or are these kind of like to help
us enjoy ourselves in life and the AIS
are sort of letting us have our fun but
we're not really needed anymore
so in a broad sense humans aren't needed
to do most of the intellectual Endeavors
but in this world in particular humans
are necessary because humans always form
the center of a group of AIS that are
pursuing any Endeavor I guess humans
might be like the corpus callosum of the
brain maybe connecting all the different
AI experts and except for the Corpus
glossum doesn't guide the Endeavor
either I guess that would be what the
frontal the point is is that humans are
an integral part of the system moving
forward all of their AI advisors are
trying to satisfy their desires but the
human is still at the helm so this is
kind of by virtue of how we've developed
AIS and these parliaments which we'll
get to later where people have these
different AI entities kind of
surrounding them and they've been built
to surround people and so that's kind of
what keeps people in the loop irrelevant
yep the specific way the AIS were
constructed and what the AIS themselves
care about
requires humans it makes sense one thing
I really appreciated reading through
your world's stories is how the
perspectives change where people start
seeing AIS as tools originally then
there's this kind of period of like AI
animism where we sort of like give them
personalities but not really seriously
like and then we eventually come to see
them more as genuine entities that
deserve rights and there's kind of this
Reckoning morally with the way we've
been treating them where do things stand
in 2045 at the end of your story at the
end of this timeline in 2045 people have
recognized ai's as not as humans but as
other people as personalities and worthy
of consideration I think that will
actually be easier than perhaps you
might expect in my story there's a
backlash against the AIS where everybody
who's been displaced by an AI or has
lost their job because of AI is angry at
them but at the end of this story
everyone has an AI advisor and has been
interacting with them for many years and
has seen their lives improve with the
help of AI in so many ways that they can
no longer view AI as mere tools because
AI has been acting like a person and
helping them for long enough that
they've come to see the AI as a friend
or at least an advisor I guess if it
looks like a human and treats you well
for a few years you'll start to
sympathize with it and I think humans
really anthropomone fries non-human
things quite a lot so even with a
pushback at the beginning of the story
it is reasonable to think that people
will treat AIS as humans but yeah
foreign
this world paints a particularly Vivid
picture of the struggles between its
competing Technologies and groups from
advertisers and AD filters to AI art
addicts and neo-vacidics tensions abound
but the authors portray these conflicts
as mostly resulting in improvements to
the world
I wanted to hear more about how we might
pull Collective victories from these
kinds of intense competitions and what
inspired our authors to imagine them
I thought it'd be good to kind of dig
into some of the different technological
conflicts that come about in your world
you have some really cool sort of
extended arcs where different
technological breakthroughs and changes
and attitudes towards technology kind of
alter our relationship to it so one
really interesting thread is this whole
social movement called neoaceticism or
knee ATS and so asceticism is this like
ancient philosophy of rejecting
Temptation and Indulgence and kind of
you know living sparely and these folks
take that stand against Indulgence in
modern Technologies in your world I
thought it was a really interesting kind
of philosophy to explore because it's
not simply like anti-technology or like
pro-nature or something like that it's
really about the use of the technology
so these folks like start out being
against you know watching too many AI
generated TV shows and things like that
but they do Embrace some forms of
technology later on which for example
allow them to like remove their sense of
sexuality from themselves or or other
things that allow them to feel more
acidic I'm just curious like what got
you to think about this perspective or
if there were particular Inspirations
for the niyats in your world
so I first imagined a backlash against
advertising rather than art or AI
generated things specifically I think
there's been a pretty strong backlash
against advertising uh in our world
already people are installing ad
blockers and they're resisting it with
whatever tools they can find so that
might be why the neats of our world are
willing to use technological tools to
resist a technological problem I expect
Air at itself to have a similar backlash
because very many people have dedicated
their lives to producing arts and seeing
that taken away from them is going to
prompt discontent at the least
unemployment is one thing but when
something you're passionate about
becomes the domain of a computer as
opposed to your own domain it will be
very upsetting yeah this is very topical
I mean you kind of saw this happening in
your submission before it really hit
culturally but now it's really in full
swing already I mean I just saw a story
the other day of a computer scientist
who released a children's book that he
made with dolly and some people are
really Furious I mean he's getting like
death threats unfortunately but you know
some people are even thoughtfully still
kind of railing against this as like
creators saying that this is a problem
for their art did you expect this to
happen so soon or have you been
surprised by this reality
it happened faster than I would have
expected uh in my timeline it happens a
year
or two from now and not not immediately
and I have to admit that the backlash
seems more immediate and stronger than I
would have expected as well
but uh I have not had my art replaced by
AI yet so maybe I I don't have a good
perspective on it right as a writer I am
worried about that yeah
and I think it's not far given chat GPT
yeah but I think the I I'd failed to
simulate the intensity of the emotions
that would be felt yeah
in your world the art becomes so good
and so personalized that it like totally
absorbs people and we have this thing of
like art paralysis syndrome can you say
a little bit about that and what that
looks like like what is that Media made
of
oh you want to know what the media
specifically looks like to those
consuming it yeah I'm curious like are
you imagining it as like a really really
good TV show that you can't stop
watching or is it some kind of like
Spiral thing that's like not intuitive
but somehow captures us
I imagine it is
a Netflix series mostly okay or a TV
show would be at an accurate way of
saying it but the specific things that
make it uh super personalized and
difficult to escape for the victims are
difficult to imagine if I can imagine
something so compelling it might
distract me after all yeah yeah
if you if if the series contains things
that
that are very heavily optimized to
engage humans it could get very
concerning so the thing that inspired
that was this incident of people playing
wow until they perished which itself is
covered in an article that Eliza Kowski
wrote on less wrong
about super stimulus
in other areas of Our Lives
like food and drink for example super
stimuluses have become available and
then people will eat food until they get
sick or until their health suffers yeah
or in the case of uh illicit substances
they'll consume substances until they
perish from their consumption
and I think we have an intuitive grasp
of that that's pretty strong everybody
understands that drug abuse or super
addictive substances can lead to bad
outcomes but the fact that video games
also can cause this suggests that even a
purely mental thing might lead to
negative Health outcomes and our
paralysis syndrome in our world is The
Logical extension in that if you
optimize the art too much people might
not be able to look away yeah I can
definitely see how the neots would find
this problematic and start mobilizing
against this kind of like Advanced media
drug essentially indeed the the movement
picks up in popularity as the
capabilities of the art generators pick
up as well I think there are people
today who fight against artificial media
even but it's a far smaller Community
because the artificial nature of media
doesn't strike most people as worthy of
a fight as as of yet yeah
the solution in your world for this
problem of art paralysis or at least one
solution involves this neurochemical
reset treatment which is like a pretty
bold concept it allows people to change
their desires effectively in their
motivations so that you can get rid of
this drive to engage with the media and
we see like the neots for example using
this technology for their own purposes
to remove their sex drives and become
asexual
so this opens up some really deep
philosophical questions about like what
should we want to want so if you can
remove your sexuality for example can't
you just as easily remove your interest
in being an ascetic like why do they do
one and not the other how should we
decide what state to put ourselves into
that's a very tough question and uh I
don't think I can answer it it's a
philosophical very individual thing
whether you should want to keep the
desires you have or fight against them a
lot of people have and by a lot of
people I mean religious people and and
moral people people considering various
things that are more important to them
than satisfaction of their desires
throughout history humans have resisted
their desires in one way or another it
seems natural to me that if there's a
technological solution people might
consider it or might even jump on it if
they think that solution is part of
keeping themselves healthy in the face
of a world trying to deceive them yeah
regarding the neats and my art Club I
got some pushback from other members of
the art club they're like there's no way
everybody would choose to be asexual or
there's no way people would alter their
personalities like that but uh
loneliness and lack of human contact is
a growing problem in our world and I
imagine the future in the future people
might be less reserved in their
willingness to fight such things yeah
if you if you keep your desires if the
neat chose to keep their desires they
might expect that to lead them to be
unhappy in the future versus removing
their desires would lead them to
happiness
you know it we can't imagine cutting out
our sexuality but if their sexuality
were a constant source of frustration
and pain they might think that cutting
it out would be far better yeah and
there's a fair contingent of people who
are just naturally asexual and a lot of
them seem happy and fine and so maybe
that's a state that they would aspire to
it's true maybe also in the future those
perspectives will be better understood
by the populists in general and more
people will be sympathetic to asexuality
so there'll be less of a knee-jerk oh
that that would be wrong sort of
reaction there is a potential Dark Side
to this it seems to me in terms of
diversity because if you're making it
relatively easy to change yourself in
pursuit of connection and you know
relating to other people that might
cause a strong drive for people to sort
of assimilate and you know if everyone
can change their favorite show to be
cheers and then all the TVs are playing
cheers all the time like that's
technically a good outcome in terms of
people enjoying televisions but like
there's also some loss there so I'm
curious about your thoughts as to how
diversity is at risk with this kind of
system or like whether it should be
maintained somehow
so Scott Alexander of Astral code X10
has this idea of universal culture where
culture tends to a minimum that all
cultures get pushed towards this
effective minimum where the most
successful policies or cultural
practices or what have you become
Universal and every other policy gets
pushed to the side because it doesn't
work as well one of the examples he
gives is Coca-Cola
Coca-Cola is uh a drink that's been
optimized for human consumption it
contains caffeine and sugar and fizzy
water and not much else it's very
heavily optimized and it's sort of a
symptom of universal culture so other
drinks like green tea or goat's milk or
I think he actually says Yaks milk at
any rate other drinks that cultures
might consume will be pushed out of the
way from this Universal Baseline
and I think it's a real problem because
if you can change your very mind maybe
someone someone seeking a job would
change their mind to best match the job
they're seeking or maybe a student
trying to get into a college would like
they currently change their Hobbies they
might change their relationship with
Hobbies or their motivation for certain
activities to look more appealing to a
to a university that's willing to admit
them so I think it's a very real risk
that the world would become more
homogenized in that case however the
story itself also provides an
explanation for why that might not
happen
there's a widely understood need for
variety and diversity and thought to the
extent that the AIS themselves
purposefully diversifying and keep
themselves from being copies from each
other and they guided their their human
charges toward hobbies that are unique
and toward unique experiences because
it's understood that having a variety of
experiences to draw from in a variety of
perspectives is more powerful so it's
hard to say what would win there's an
incentive to be like everybody else and
to match the well-known good
characteristics but there's also uh
known and accepted push for diversity I
can't say which would be more powerful
in the end when one hopes the diversity
just for the sake of entertaining this
and for us not all being cloned to each
other well there's also in your world
this the technology allows for extreme
personalization like we see with the the
art being so powerful for individuals so
you could imagine like while Coca-Cola
is a great solution for Mass
manufacturing if you could make a drink
that was tailored to each person's
mouths and taste sensors and past
experiences maybe there would be like a
million different coca-colas that would
only appeal to 10 people but would be
like the best drinks ever for them so
you can kind of imagine the same kinds
of personalizing Technologies pushing
back against this as well
go even further tailor it to their
current mood and their current
expectations or maybe their current
blood sugar or whatever else they care
about
uh they might end up drinking the fluid
all day and neglecting other Foods
interesting although hopefully in in my
world that person would have an advisor
saying hey you need nutrition as well
and uh nutrition is important enough
that we're going to request it of the AI
building the drink so that you don't get
a nutritional deficiency and you'd be
like okay yeah sure and your drink takes
tastes imperceptively worse but you get
better nutrition yeah
so I'd like to talk a little bit about
some of the different challenges that
your world faced in getting to that
position where we can appreciate and
respect AI systems and in the very
beginning we really struggle to keep
these EI systems under control and one
early approach that you spelled out is
Death Drive which is basically this
strong self-destructive urge where these
AI systems want to destroy themselves
and they will unless they're actively
countered over time so the idea is that
if they become misaligned somehow or
kind of go loose or go Rogue then that
Death Drive will be triggered and
they'll destroy themselves and render
themselves you know inert but I was
wondering doesn't this kind of make
these systems into hostages like
wouldn't they have some kind of
resentment if that's not too
anthropomorphizing for these early AI
systems and how do you see this Dynamic
impacting the behaviors or utility of
these systems like wouldn't they want to
find ways to destroy themselves Without
You realizing
um yes that's a that's a risk so there
are two things going on here the first
and this is very important to say death
drive is not a good alignment strategy
it's uh meant to be a knee jerk oh we'll
solve the problem any way we can here's
one way that might at a first glance
plausibly work and actually if you
consider it deeply you'll realize many
flaws with this one of them is explored
in the story which is that a system May
incorrectly delineate its own boundaries
and Destroy other systems that are
similar to it yeah but there are other
ways this can fail the second is uh to
the extent that the system is
intelligent and sentient Death Drive is
uh not a applicable strategy you have to
imagine that in the beginning these
systems are subscentient they just want
to shut themselves off they're
optimizing for a signal being removed if
they actually reach sentience and they
had something like a a unified mind
seeking that thing resentment would come
into play but these are subsystems that
are not sentient at least in the
beginning
it's it's fair to characterize them as
hostages it's not a good situation and
there's a reason it's seen as a
widespread tragedy but rather than
shutting off an entire mind it would be
like removing a piece of your brain when
it deviated sufficiently I see yeah I
guess like cells do that apoptosis
indeed and to get cells to behave
coherently they have to have an off
switch and something like that happens
in the AI here but again it's not a
reasonable alignment strategy it's just
one one possibility you might consider
when trying to solve alignment
another thing that's worth saying about
it is that as evolved organisms humans
and other animals have a very strong
aversion to death and as you would
expect it's so strong and natural that
even questioning it it almost sounds
insane to say oh well what what if there
was someone or something that preferred
to die
of course octopuses for example when
they reproduce they they die or insects
like ants and bees will go into
situations that are overwhelmingly fatal
without hesitation and part of the
reason is because evolution in them
hasn't installed as strong of an
inversion to death and I think our
aversion to death is not actually
inherent to mind so the Death Drive was
also an attempt to communicate that that
you might be able to construct a mind
that was more accepting or willing with
the possibility yeah but again uh not a
good strategy gotta say that again don't
don't try this strategy for alignment
I really appreciated how like later on
in your world you know there is this
moral Reckoning where people look back
and we're like oh that was a bad idea
and like they feel really terrible for
having instilled this death drive into
these systems and for not really
considering that they may have true
sentience and and you know should have
rights but I was wondering if there are
other sort of moral errors that you
could imagine them catching even later
down the line like after 2045 I mean as
we said earlier these systems are built
inherently to surround and support human
beings why does that have to be the case
is there something kind of subservient
about that or something that might be
morally questionable about creating
these beings just to support us I'm sure
there is uh I don't know if the humans
of my story will view it in a negative
light and they'll probably just view it
as a fact of life but creating beings
just to be servants is fraught with
moral problems that uh we didn't really
explore in this timeline
there's this thread in your story about
advertisers and filters kind of fighting
back and forth right now that looks like
people coming up with ads mostly on
websites this happens I think and then
you have like ad blockers people install
and they go back and forth I'd like to
hear more about what it looks like in
the advanced version in your story like
are these filters just an ultra reliable
review system where you kind of take
anonymized data from everyone around you
and you say like hey are these pants
really good pants and if everyone says
yeah for someone like you these are good
pants then you buy them like is that
kind of the basis of this technology as
an advanced filter I think you've got it
uh that is indeed the idea I had that
these AI systems would ping each other
for information and look for other
purchases and outcomes that has been
anonymized and then is communicated to
them then they they do a Bayesian update
they're like well given all of the
things I know about the human I'm trying
to purchase pants for what is the chance
that they'll be satisfied with this
purchase
it makes it hard for companies to use
advertising in any way because the AI is
like okay nice ad but the other AI I'm
talking to have said these things yeah
that's fascinating and thus the ad based
internet can continue to exist because
ads are never seen by a human AI filters
them out and considers them for what
they are well in a way it sounds like
the AI is the filter is becoming the
advertising system sort of I mean it's a
true system like it's not gonna
overstate things or misrepresent them
but if you make a good product and
people like it like your your filters
will be your advertisers and they'll
tell everyone to buy your product
exactly uh supercharged Word of Mouth
yeah might be a good way to describe it
genuinely good products are very quickly
recognized and taken up in under this
Paradigm it's an interesting way to
think it almost makes advertising seem
like a poor solution to like a lack of
communication between everyone like if
everyone could just talk really
efficiently and accurately about like
their pants purchases we wouldn't need
pants commercials like we're stuck with
the commercial yeah well I mean one of
the valid functions of advertising is
making you aware of a product for
example
so all the ways advertising is
incentivized to trick you are still true
but if we stay advertising makes you
aware of a product if you had somebody
who specifically goes out and looks for
the product for you that would make that
last good thing of advertising less
relevant and then maybe advertising
wouldn't be necessary you talk about how
this basically leads to the end of the
ad-based internet
can you say a little about what comes
after or what that turns into so instead
of an internet where you browse to a
website and you look at the website as
it wants to present itself and you view
the same thing as everyone else what
happens is when you want to learn about
something or get some sort of
information you tell one of your AIS one
of your filters or your advisors
depending on what part of the timeline
that you want to learn about this thing
they'll go out and gather the
information for you and then present it
in a digestible way for you specifically
the web pages are all built on the fly
so they're not really web pages anymore
they're custom presentations of
information yeah the Wikipedia page is
Rewritten so that the things that you're
specifically looking for are right there
and available and everything that's most
interesting to you is organized and
presented in a way that's easy for you
and particular to understand it's hard
to describe exactly how that would be
implemented but it would be implemented
uniquely for every person and very
efficiently and immediately yeah I mean
I can actually imagine that much better
now than I could a few weeks ago because
I've been playing with chat GPT so much
and it has that kind of flavor I mean
I've really been able to explain my
particular circumstances and preferences
to it and then ask it a question and it
gives me a personalized answer I
wouldn't be able to find anywhere online
and seven or eight years before I would
have thought that would exist yeah yeah
is that also surprising to you how fast
that happened uh yes I'm I'm very
impressed with chat GPT more than it's
it's more capable than I would have
expected at this point I've been shocked
and I thought I was being pessimistic
about how fast these things were going
to be like uh or optimistic depending on
your perspective I didn't expect it to
advance as fast well one thing I've
noticed I think a lot of people have
noticed the chat GPT is it's it's very
fluent it's very convincing and well
written but sometimes it'll get things
wrong it'll get little details incorrect
it's just you know it hasn't quite
picked up on some details how do you
manage that in these kinds of systems
where everyone is reading their own
website like how do you know if you can
trust the specifics of what you're air
filter is telling you how do you know
your filter doesn't have something
slightly wrong somewhere if there's
nothing to compare to
so this isn't something that I
specifically tried to address in the
original timeline but ideally you set it
up so there are two or more competing
incentives to get things accurate such
that if something is presented
inaccurately part of the system as a
whole will notice or have incentive to
notice and tell you about it it's not an
easy problem to solve yeah I mean it
sounds like that's sort of an analogy to
like how Wikipedia works right now where
you have some people who volunteer to go
and fact check maybe you have like an AI
whose job it is to go and kind of look
over everyone's shoulder and make sure
they're not being lied to by their
filters yeah perhaps the skeptic and the
enthusiastic subsystem yeah
the eventual solution to kind of
balancing these different AI systems in
your world is these Parliament
structures which it sounds like is kind
of like what you were just describing
um you have these multiple AI systems
that are all working together and kind
of checking each other's work and
they're in some kind of balance can you
say a little bit about how that works
and is it kind of like a governmental
solution
so it was hard to pick a word for what
to call these I I chose Parliament and I
imagined like a a ring of of entities
that were all
simultaneously vying for control of the
AI or the ai's attention but it's not
governmental it's more I would say it's
more biological even okay
so a couple of things inspired that one
was this book called Crystal Society
where there's an AI That's composed of
four sentient subsystems that all fight
for the control of the AI as a whole
I was imagining non-sentient Parliament
members so to speak non-sentient uh
subsystems
but in that book their Ascension and
they fight with each other and in the
first book in particular their major
plot point is which subsystem is going
to gain control
so that inspired it the other thing that
inspired it was the way birds have song
clusters within their brains that each
each focus on different parts of the
birds and activities
so human brains and bird brains are
arranged a little bit differently invert
brains there are these clusters which
communicate with each other but are
otherwise small locally centralized
Computing you know well computing's not
the right word but processing centers
yeah that inspired these parliaments as
well so a bird's group of song clusters
is sort of like an ai's group of
parliaments the parliaments all
interface with each other but they uh
have other interactions besides each one
competing to decide what next action or
next overall thing is going to is going
to happen yeah well it sounds like in
Crystal Society for example this is not
necessarily a stable system right like
how do you ensure that this vying for
power stays static over time and one of
them doesn't win and kind of take over
the system there needs to be a pretty
well designed feedback mechanism and I
don't think uh I could design it or even
describe it quickly but maybe you could
do it like uh a brain does it where the
region after exerting itself gets tired
and can no longer can no longer make
decisions in this case these AI these NN
chips these neural network chips they
they can't self-alter for example so
they're a little bit more constrained in
the specific actions they might take and
neural network chips are also not
easily copyable
so you don't have to worry about one
just copying its own code and and
deleting all the others like in a mammal
or a bird brain you don't have to worry
about a cluster of neurons duplicating
itself and taking over the whole brain
but that's sort of a hand wave actually
making these things not you know making
one of them not get a little bit smarter
and then co-opt the goals of the other
ones is a significant Challenge and I
don't have a good answer that how to
prevent it yeah that makes me also
wonder like the goal of these
parliaments it seems to me is to kind of
balance these different intending
entities whatever they are and keep them
in check so that none of them gets too
much power but as you were describing
the way that birds work and as we think
of other collectives that kind of behave
in a coherent way you could imagine the
whole Parliament itself having desires
that kind of come together and are
themselves damaging so like
does that cause another control problem
or you need like parliaments of
parliaments or something
so there are many incentive structures
in this story at different levels if one
of the AI advisors for example is acting
aberrantly that becomes apparent to the
other AI advisors and they have an
incentive to correct to the behavior of
the aberrant one so yes you do need a
control scheme at the higher level I see
so each AI advisor is like this
Parliament it's composed of these
subsystems and then the AI advisors also
work with each other to support a person
indeed
and if one of them starts trying to grab
resources for itself for example
although that I think the first sign is
going to be far subtler than that uh at
any rate if one of them tries to grab
resources that it doesn't need or
behaves in a nefarious fashion and the
other is working with it will notice
this and resist it and punish it for
that the system that's going to behave
that way understands as much and so
behaves correctly from the get-go and
perhaps even if one of its subsystems is
misleading it then it might even excise
its own subsystem and replace it
from an economic perspective your world
is also pretty well situated I mean like
things are fairly well distributed by
the end of it but I really love how this
came about which is basically due to a
use of corporate greed this is a really
fun Arc where you have corporations kind
of realizing that there's so much
inequality that they can't get enough
money from like the impoverished people
at the bottom and they start lobbying to
redistribute wealth so that they can
then get more of that money back and
they're they're going to redistribute
wealth as long as it hurts their
competitors slightly more than
themselves so this creates kind of like
this race to the bottom but what keeps
this kind of economic upheaval from
actually being useful for corporations
like what if a few corporations actually
won and came out on top and got more
money in the end instead of creating a
more equal Society
so if there were a single ton of
Corporations then that would be game
over for that possibility for the Ubi
but if there are multiple competing
corporations and you also have
extraordinarily good feedback from the
AI advisors the aafs I think there could
be a shorter name there from the
advisors we'll just call them advisors
even though they predate the advisors in
the story if your advisors allow you to
determine which products are actually
good and there are still a couple
corporations competing then they might
launch new divisions to compete with
each other and sap each other's money
and products will become genuinely good
yeah the other thing that's absolutely
required is startups and new
corporations to form
maybe uh I'm trying to come up with a
good metaphor a metaphor for it we were
talking about buying pants earlier so
maybe there's somebody who can stitch a
really good pair of pants and it's going
to be extremely expensive because
they're not you know mechanized
industrialized or what have you but they
make a pair of pants and then they try
and sell it through their AI advisors
and someone else says hey this local
producer of pants who lives down the
road can make you a pair of pants for
this much more than the corporate entity
that might be the the seeding point for
a new startup and to the extent to that
a person working on their own can truly
make a higher quality pair of pants than
the corporate entity they'll gang
they'll gain funds they'll gain money
they might be able to teach their skills
to other people and grow a whole new
corporation that can compete with the
larger one so these corporations that
start the Ubi they try and use Ubi as a
mechanism to steal money from each other
because there's no there's well steel is
not correct either but to acquire money
from each other because there's no other
way to get the maybe steel is correct
that's that's debatable
um I won't answer whether stealing is
correct for this the point is they're
trying to get money from each other
through whatever mechanism and they try
they they run out of other mechanisms so
they use Ubi not accounting for the fact
that with AI Assistance disruptors or
new corporations will have a much better
chance at succeeding and and in turn
winning you know the money that they had
hoped to gain from the other
corporations
so Ubi Universal basic income is this
concept where everyone gets some money
just for existing and that gives kind of
a baseline of standard of living and so
these corporations are pushing for
everyone including other corporations to
have to pitch in for this is that what's
going on and then they're going to try
to get that money back pretty much if
you're not already over 50 percent but
you think you're going to acquire more
than whatever percent of the current
economy you are of the Ubi it's a net
and it's a net increase right yeah if
one corporation's like I'm 20 of the
economy right now which is kind of a
terrifying thing to imagine but one
corporation's like I'm 20 of the economy
but I can gain 40 of Ubi payments then
from their perspective BBI is a good
deal they'll net gang from it yeah and
they'll Lobby for it yeah and so the
thing that makes this all turn good I
guess
is basically this like radical quality
transparency like pushing us towards a
meritocracy where anyone who can really
do something useful will be recognized
and noticed by these AI systems and
lifted up to compete yep it's working
under the premise that the reason that
capitalism and the current market
doesn't satisfy needs perfectly is at
least partially from lack of
transparency yeah interesting
foreign
assistants are a common Trope in pop
culture and one of the more common
features in the submissions we received
this world takes them through a
particularly strong developmental Arc
they grow and change constantly and harm
relationships with them grow and change
as well
sometimes we catch up a little slower
than perhaps we should but eventually
they are recognized as sentient beings
deserving of their own rights they're
still not like us but they are also not
less than us
this is a difficult moment of moral
Reckoning for Humanity and a humbling
reminder that simply creating something
isn't enough to truly understand it
I was curious what inspired this complex
moral portrait of artificial assistance
and what Mark thought about other ways
they've been portrayed in the media
so I'd like to take a bit to talk about
different ways that our culture is
currently kind of treating things like
personal assistance and AI tools and how
that relates to the way that your story
portrays them so how do you think most
people are currently thinking about
personal assistance in the future and
how do you think that these recent
advances like Chad gbt have impacted
this Jazzy BT is changing on a daily
basis I'm not sure what its ultimate
effect is going to be thus far personal
assistants have not taken off as well as
anyone would have predicted they're not
as uh perhaps capable as people wish
that may change 10 gbt is very capable
or it seems that way now but there's
sort of an effect with AI generated art
and text where at first it will seem
extraordinarily capable as time goes on
people will become more cognizant of its
limitations and those limitations will
jump out at them yeah
so I think there's a distrust of
assistance right now and that distrust
might persist for a while because the
little indicators that the assistant is
not genuine or is is incapable will
continually jump out
yeah that makes sense we're amazed now
and indeed it is an amazing development
but I think in some weeks or months
we'll probably say well chechi PT speaks
with such a soulless voice
and it speaks with certainty but is very
verbose and and lacking in conciseness
and and punch in what it's saying so P I
think in in shortly people will
recognize chat GPT text as for what it
is
and then an upgrade will be made and it
will be amazing again and eventually
that will probably lead to the point
where the assistant does generate text
that you can't distinguish from humans
yeah
I I don't know when that point will be
reached maybe sooner than I thought it
seems that way perhaps
are there any examples of like really
complex and nuanced portrayals of
personal assistance and fiction that
inspired you when you were working on
this
I'm having a really hard time thinking
of any I'm sure I was inspired by things
but they're not they're not available
of course there's a pretty notable
exception in data from Star Trek that's
true data is a full character of the
show it's not quite like the timeline
here because there aren't very many
datas running around there's only one
and he's pretty unique but it is an
example of a robotic assistant that's
actually a character yeah I'm not super
familiar with Star Trek lore but like is
data meant to be an assistant to
somebody on the crew or is he sort of
just like an independent tool for the
whole organization
he's a crew member but one that's Nai
and thus has unique capabilities I I
gotta admit that I'm not as familiar
with Star Trek as many either but
cultural osmosis has communicated a lot
about data to me yeah yeah
he's a very calm voiced rational direct
perfect crew member essentially although
perhaps not perfect to the show
undoubtedly explores his imperfections
or ways that he could be more human or
more capable but I do think it is a a
close betrayal to the sort of assistant
I was imagining imagine if the entire
crew was composed of datas with
different personalities that might be
like how the story goes in my timeline
in this in this short fiction we wrote
yeah
one thing that's strongly represented in
your story is this kind of Developmental
Arc where the AIS themselves are
changing and growing and they have this
Dynamic nature they're not just like a
tool that kind of stays the same
throughout I'm wondering if Technologies
like Chad gbt and things like that and
they're on rapid development will kind
of change how we think about these tools
going forward thus far it seems like
every new tool is a separate entity
distinct from those that came before
although there are exceptions to that
novel AI anime image generation tool has
been receiving updates that change how
it functions so maybe it will change in
the future where we view these things as
capable of change and Improvement but
thus far it seems like they're distinct
tools as opposed to things that are
improving
gradually yeah
was there anything that you were
consciously trying to get people to
think differently about as you were
writing your world
so earlier we talked about death Drive I
wish I could write a story in which I
could adequately explain how
uh the desire to avoid death is a very
human and living animal thing and not
necessarily a component of all Minds so
I did want to make that a part of the
story although it's not as Central as
some other themes another one is that
collaborative efforts with small groups
of people are far more successful and
rewarding than I think most people
realize I think isolation and the
feeling of isolation
has overtaken our culture pretty
significantly more people than ever feel
lonely and isolated and
reminding people that they can go and
collaborate with each other and work
together and Achieve things even things
that might seem small on scale but just
involve working with other people
whether it be through an online tool or
in the case of my story with advisors
that are almost other people that's what
I wish to convey was the joy of doing
that yeah that is interesting how a lot
of our social Technologies seem to have
really expanded our reach so broadly but
also sort of made it thinner and you can
imagine this return to like narrower and
deeper relationships with with a smaller
group of people around you that's
exactly what I hope happens and uh I
think in the future we will have ways
and have the sense to do that nowadays
if you wanted to work with a small group
of people you might try Discord instead
of Reddit or Twitter yeah like your art
Club yeah exactly
I I think I mentioned earlier that Dart
Club inspired this story quite a lot
directly we work together on Art in art
club and in my story The AIS and the and
the human work together on their
Endeavors as well yeah did you create
this structure of like a regularly
meeting Art Club where you would share
and critique each other's work or were
you inspired by other groups you've seen
I'm not sure who started the art Club it
actually used to be a writing Club
specifically but we broadened the things
that we might talk about the idea of
just getting together and talking about
things probably did come from somewhere
specific but it's it's lost we have no
idea who suggested forming a small Art
Club if an artist takes anything from
listening to this interview it should be
that you can message a few friends and
start an art club and change the way you
relate to Art and improve your art
immensely just as easily as that the
tools are there the if you don't have
friends you can think of immediately you
can find them online yeah yeah uh
there's nothing stopping anyone from
making a group of five people who are
working together on a project yeah I
really like this concept it's been
inspiring for me to think about in my
own life like I know a lot of really
creative people I do a lot of Creator
projects myself and it would be great to
just you know have a small group where
you kind of follow each other's work
over time it's a cool way to combine
expertise too like one thing we're
trying to do at a larger scale with this
competition is just get people talking
that have different perspectives and
expertise so like having an art club
with like some engineers in it sounds
great and just like see what they think
of the stuff you're doing yep uh but not
only Engineers if you if you have only
engineers and know and no artists in the
art Club it's an engineering club
so one interesting implication of the AI
assistance in your world is this kind of
like anonymized network of feedback
that's kind of built into the filtering
systems and you mentioned you gave a
small example of like maybe what you eat
for lunch could impact how people treat
you or who wants to hang out with you
and you wouldn't entirely know why or be
aware of this interaction I'm curious if
you could kind of expand on that and say
what you were imagining like how that
might work
so as I'm imagining a specific instance
that might happen in real life where a
person goes out to lunch and they eat
something with garlic in it and then
they have an interview with an employer
later that day and they don't realize
that their choice of what they ate for
lunch is negatively impacting their
interview
in this world an AI might detect what
you ate for lunch and make an inference
about how it means you're going to
interact with other people and then tell
those people to avoid you because
it might be as small as eating Garlic
but they if they have very many friends
they might hang out with they might
avoid you because you chose to eat
garlic for lunch right and uh that's a
that's a risk you might face with
perfect information exchange the AI
might be able to infer things about your
activities or maybe unfairly assume
things about your activities because
from its perspective oh yeah one percent
chance of a negative interaction is not
worth it might as well go the other way
all of them simultaneously make that
choice and suddenly no one wants to hang
out with you after lunch yeah this could
be like a very subtle and Insidious form
of discrimination against different
types of people I could imagine like if
someone really loves garlic maybe you
know they won't have any friends anymore
in this world because everyone's AI so
be like yeah it's not really worth
getting to know Bob like yeah which
would be indeed a tragic and and
Insidious form of discrimination that's
a good way of saying it and it might
also be the case that your own AI push
you towards that homogeneity by Yeah by
telling you to eat less garlic yeah
maybe they change your brain so you
don't like garlic anymore and then the
garlic industry collapses well I think I
think they would not jump to straight to
changing your brain maybe maybe a few
months after you quit garlic and your
Cravings become overwhelming
if you're a garlic addict yeah I also
curious how how this sort of system
relates to social Credit Systems I mean
I see some parallels where you have this
overarching system that is like
assessing you and trying to give you
some kind of overall score or like guide
the parts of society you can participate
in based on some forms of Merit is there
a connection there for you so I don't
understand current social Credit Systems
as they exist uh as well as it would
take to to comment on them sure so they
didn't influence the story very much but
one would hope that the use of
individual systems for making decisions
like that would alleviate some of the
concerns from a broader social credit
system your score in a social credit
system doesn't adequately reflect who
you are and uh with sentient advisors
maybe they would have a better idea of
who you are when they're making
recommendations for you or guiding you
and to go back to the garlic metaphor
maybe they'd say okay he ate garlic but
all these other parts of his personality
are worth considering too yeah
yeah or if we've if we've succeeded in
maintaining diversity and we have a lot
of different perspectives and
preferences in the world you might find
somebody who loves the smell of garlic
breath yeah like your AI will just find
you the perfect friend yeah or somebody
who doesn't notice the smell of garlic
breath yeah yeah can't smell things or
maybe uh maybe somebody who quickly goes
past such such foibles yeah or someone
who likes to light candles in the room
that overpower the smell but like who
knows there could be a million ways that
garlic is not an issue and they eyes
will be better at finding that than a
social credit system would be right so
it's kind of like the the dimensionality
of it it's not like you have a single
number and if your number's Bad No One's
Gonna hang out with you it's like you
have a particular way of being and maybe
that fits or doesn't fit with everyone
else's complicated ways of being but
there's always going to be somewhere you
fit in and can hopefully particular in
society
yep or there's always going to be
someone who can advise you on the least
disruptive way to fit in better right
yeah interesting
[Music]
the process of World building has great
potential to make a positive future feel
more attainable
this can be incredibly powerful whether
you're a creative person looking to
produce Rich works of fiction or have a
more technical focus and are looking to
reach policy makers or the public
I asked Mark what kind of impact he
hoped his work would have on the world
so I have some questions about what you
hope comes of the work that you Natalia
and Patrick have created which aspects
of your world would you most like to see
taken on in popular media
it would be it would be good if there
was more popular media depicting Minds
that are different from ours in subtle
ways it's a really hard thing to do
because people auto complete the pattern
an example of data data is not so much
an Android as another human with a with
an emotional disorder brand yeah yeah so
depicting how Minds might be subtly
different is a great Challenge and I
hope more people take it up especially
since mines do vary in subtle ways and
thinking about such things will help us
relate with each other better yeah are
there some examples I know you've
already spoken to like the fear of death
being something that we kind of assume
is a default in all sorts of minds but
maybe isn't are there other ways that
Minds vary that you would like to see
explored
the the thing that interests me isn't
even just that the minds vary it's it's
how two minds That Vary interact with
each other and come to consensus so a
couple of fiction stories I read long
ago
contain this really well particularly
The Works of Kim Stanley Robinson he's a
science fiction author you've probably
read something of his if I had to guess
I have yeah the thing that makes that
series really great is the human
characteristics yeah all of the people
in that have different things they care
about and they're interacting with each
other trying to forward their goals but
they they do have different things they
care about so maybe rather than
different Minds it's these different
people's goals and their interactions
and how they how they come to support
and work with each other despite these
different things they care about that is
something I find really compelling in
which I saw more of yeah what do you
think are some of the positive impacts
of people just creating more positive
stories about the world positive impacts
of positive stories yeah uh there's this
effect where people will talk about a
really cool possible technology and
someone else will be like I'm gonna make
that real or I'm gonna do I try right
apparently Star Trek and and cell phones
fall into that category part of the
reason flip phones became the thing was
because of the Star Trek Communicator
although I think Star Trek isn't unique
in thinking of personal communication
devices but the the point stands that
science fiction can sometimes illuminate
a path and then make that path come true
so there's a lot of utility in it for
that in addition to telling a compelling
story these compelling possibilities
might make themselves real yeah it's
interesting how new developments and
Technology sort of reveal new possible
things to tell stories about like we we
kind of feel this slight lack of
coverage of what AI assistance could be
like in fiction but maybe there will be
more and more of that as people start
really dreaming about what chat GPT
could turn into or how Dolly might
affect things stuff like that maybe a
fiction author will discover a really
good use for such a system and then
we'll make it so yeah
what do you hope that your world leaves
people thinking about long after they've
read through it
thinking about how today they can
message their friends and get to work on
a collaborative project as opposed to
as opposed to waiting for AI to come in
and help them with all of their work
that's great they're humans now who
would love to help you they won't be uh
as perfectly expert as the AI in this
fiction but they don't need to be for
great things to happen yeah call to
creative action I guess that's that's it
a call to creative action
doesn't necessarily have to be art maybe
the robotics club's a good idea too yeah
well this has been a great conversation
Mark uh thank you so much for your time
and thank you to Natalia and Patrick and
everyone else at Art Club for the work
that you put into this awesome world I
really appreciate you coming on here to
share it further with us I really
appreciate the opportunity to talk about
it a bit more it's fun to consider these
ideas more deeply and see where they
might be expanded or where where other
people could add to it or what things
are left to unresolved for sure so it
was it was fun being on the podcast
[Music]
Our Guest today was Mark L if you'd like
to explore some more of Mark's Work you
can check out his recent book rays of
intent a collection of rational short
stories this book was actually another
team effort as Natalia helped to write
it and Patrick created the cover art
you can also read more of Mark's stories
on his Archive of Our Own account his
username there is blasted zero glass
that's blasted the number zero and then
glass in one word
[Music]
if this podcast has got you thinking
about the future you can find out more
about this world and explore the ideas
contained in the other worlds at
www.worldbuild.ai we want to hear your
thoughts are these worlds you'd want to
live in
if you've enjoyed this episode and would
like to help more people discover and
discuss these ideas you can give us a
rating or leave a comment wherever
you're listening to this podcast you
read all the comments and appreciate
every rating this podcast is produced
and edited by worldview studio and the
future of Life Institute fli is a
non-profit that works to reduce
large-scale risks from transformative
Technologies and promote the development
and use of these Technologies to benefit
all life on Earth we run educational
Outreach and grants programs and
advocate for better policy making in the
United Nations U.S government and
European Union institutions if you're a
Storyteller working on Films or other
creative projects about the future we
can also help you understand the science
and storytelling potential of
transformative Technologies
if you'd like to get in touch with us or
any of the teams featured on the podcast
to collaborate you can email World build
futureoflife.org a reminder this podcast
explores the ideas created as part of
fli's World building contest and our
hope is that this series Sparks
discussion about the kinds of Futures we
all want
the ideas we discuss here are not to be
taken as fli positions
you can find more about our work at
www.futureoflife.org or subscribe to our
newsletter to get updates on all our
projects
thanks for listening to imagine a world
stay tuned to explore more positive
futures
foreign